that would go all the way to the back
into the bathroom so i don't wait for my
mom to go help a customer
or there had to be one customer there
that my mom would trust so i didn't have
to be there
yeah and so i had to [ __ ] wait and
then she got down and she went over to
go help the customer i'm gonna go to the
back to go to the bathroom
and i went to the bathroom i was like i
have to jack off
there's only one way there was the only
way
to solve this problem that dingy little
bathroom at my parents store
at a beauty supply store i [ __ ]
whacked off
with the fury and i remember that's the
first time i jacked off standing up
oh wow i've never jacked off standing up
before yeah right
and after that i was like i'll just jack
off in the shower like it's such an easy
cleanup
you had an epiphany yeah and it started
unfolding in five
four three two one hello everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast we have edric in the house
once again
hey yo yo how y'all doing
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i've been taking a lot of uh like cbd
[ __ ] uh-huh
one thing i noticed about cbd it doesn't
last long so it's like um
it definitely helps right it helps you
relax and all this other stuff but it
lasts about an
hour oh really that's it an hour for you
it doesn't last very long
at least you feel the effects i mean
like i told you last time
but then i was only taking uh pure cbd
yeah you have a little bit of thc
in there yeah well the one that i got is
uh actually from my buddy
uh han's company i can't remember the
name right now but you guys probably saw
it in my story but
um i don't want to misquote their name
and give somebody else business but
uh his gummies are pretty good like i
felt the
the quote-unquote like type of almost
like body height but that without
feeling like the the mental
yeah yeah the head change the head
changes yeah which was really great
yeah but the problem with that was like
i was i had to do a conference call
i did not give a [ __ ] about what was
going on i said i'm feeling too good but
i was like trying to say something very
like coherent
but it's not you don't really you don't
get high yeah but because you're so
relaxed yeah you don't really pay
attention to anything that's going on
yeah like it's a mental thing i just
don't give a [ __ ] yeah yeah and so
forgot what they were saying and i just
started rambling off and they're like
what was that and i'm like i don't know
i said don't worry about it
i'm just feeling really good yeah but
then like the uh the cbd gummies have
they kind of help out like they feel i'm
not sure about the inflammation part
which i know that a lot of people say it
helps with yeah i think if you have like
severe arthritis
like that's where they can feel the
effects of it but i know it helps me
relax like it makes me feel good
that's what i need some of my something
to help me relax i got too much stress
too much anxiety
i don't sleep well take cbd man it does
help uh
it won't when marielle took cbd stuff
she goes i don't
she goes i don't feel anything crazy i'm
like you're not supposed to what the
[ __ ] are you talking about you're not
supposed to get like high off your
[ __ ] mind
that's a common misconception you know
people think that you're just gonna get
high and it's like no
that's not that's not what it's about
you know people who have anxiety
or they have trouble like getting into
this relaxed state
you will feel the effects of cbd those
are the people you could see a stark
difference
if you don't deal with anxiety and
you're pretty calm person why take it
yeah
you know unless you have inflammation
issues or stuff like that but
when i took uh when i think the cbd it
helps out a lot it feels good
but mario's like high energy right so it
might help her to kind of just
you know cool i mean it's funny because
she's like should i take some cbd i'm
like what are you needed for you're
about to [ __ ] knock out in two
seconds
okay she has no problem sleeping no dude
just kos
yeah we'll get into the one of the most
annoying things that marielle does
is that we'll get into like an argument
maybe right before we sleep so i have a
general rule
is that before we go to sleep don't
argue with me yeah yeah because i'm
gonna be [ __ ] up
exactly you're not gonna be able to
sleep this girl she'll be able to
[ __ ] round me up and then three
seconds later all i hear
how the [ __ ] are you sleeping right now
like you're a terrible person yeah
and she wakes up the next day she goes
are you still mad and i'm like
i haven't slept yeah he said i'm even
worse i'm even more passionate yeah i
was like i
literally haven't slept and you just
knocked out like nothing happened
yeah you know you know who's narcoleptic
like that is it john
you know yeah this dude is
straight like i i would not be surprised
if he got diagnosed with narcolepsy like
this
really he like that literally
like that he [ __ ] passes out like you
get in the car
his head's already dropped the moment he
sits that's hilarious i'm like how i
don't understand how you do that bro
like how
the [ __ ] do you like he never sleeps
that dude literally never sleeps
who john no not john hoe oh
john kwan doctor john kwan johno
oh no no john john hoe is is on a normal
sleep cycle now because he has a
daughter he
is a kid yeah so i mean he used to be
narcoleptic like i mean not narcoleptic
insomniac like us
but uh no john quan dr john he just
knocks out he's a [ __ ] narcoleptic
he's had that problem since like bro one
time
uh in high school we were at the park
uh we we met up at the park to like uh
just get
smoke a cigarette real quick before we
went home and we were out late
and then so i think like we split up
maybe around like i don't know
4am right and then uh in the morning
um his mom is looking for him like hey
uh you know were you with john last
night i was like what i mean we all
split up really he didn't come home
he's like no he didn't come home like do
you know what i'm like nah
i don't know what turns out this dude
got into his car
started his engine and knocked down my
god
dude the park was next to elementary
school he woke up when kids started
getting chopped off at school that's
[ __ ] funny
so he was knocked out for like a solid
three hours three and a half or
four hours in the car who's he's so
tired from no that's just how he grows
bro he just knocks out
like he trust me man you would be
shocked at the times this guy knocks out
he doesn't even seem tired but then
you just give him a second of pause
that's [ __ ] funny and he's out he's
wrong he
thought he was probably a pervert for
sleeping in front of an elementary
school and [ __ ] yeah
they're like what the [ __ ] are you doing
here for three hours exactly he's
[ __ ] dicks out his head
he said his gas tank was almost on empty
oh my god dude so he had the car on yeah
he had the engine on
he started the engine to go home and the
crazy [ __ ] is
this will live like a quarter mile away
oh my god dude that's [ __ ] hilarious
yeah but you know there's so many
incidents where like
this guy just knocks out at the most
inconvenient time dude
he's lucky man i wish i could do that oh
he's caused like accidents bro because
you knock out while he's driving oh my
god you should not drive
well not drive even if you're feeling
like an ounce of fatigue you know
i know that um the weird thing is i get
sleepy in in cars
so if i drive a a long distance the
moment
i start i just i just pull over oh man
you know what's the worst bro is um
when like you riding in the car with
other people and you pass out
and then you [ __ ] get a uh you know
you get wood from from that you know
what i'm talking about
the morning no and you don't even
realize it sometimes and you get out the
car and you're like
oh you know i got into this uh
when i when i was in college you want
speaking of [ __ ] narcolepsy you
actually just triggered a memory for me
yeah
so when i was in college uh so there's a
buddy of mine who went to my same
elementary school and i think he went to
my same high school too we just never
kicked it
but uh this [ __ ] was sleep so
easily
all over the place right and this is the
thing about this guy
yeah his name is scott scott's a really
nice [ __ ] dude right
really cool chill-ass [ __ ] right
problem with him is
i remember he used to get irritated at
me because i was not doing well in
school yeah
right but there are certain i wasn't
doing well in school not because i'm not
smart i just didn't give a [ __ ] about uc
riverside yeah
i hate this [ __ ] school yeah but we
ended up taking one course together in
college where
uh i never showed up to class ever
at all right i ended up getting a b and
he ended up getting like a c
minus or something barely passable right
and he went to class every day was
studying his ass off
and i remember this was so irritated
because i kept on calling him stupid
first of all that's [ __ ] up but the
guy would always like be on me about not
going to class but i'm like what the
[ __ ] i need to go to class for didn't do
anything for you
dumb [ __ ] you know but
he uh we went to we would go he was from
sacramento so we would drive to
sacramento
this is actually almost [ __ ] killed
me so we're in sacramento
and from l.a to sacramento it's roughly
about a five and a half hour maybe a six
hour drive depending on how slow or fast
you get yeah yeah
uh we're in modesto at this point
modesto is about an hour and a half away
from sacramento maybe an hour
tops right yeah so i see this full
starting to fall asleep it's about 6am
in the morning and we usually leave at
night because we have stuff to do during
the daytime yeah so he's
i could see him getting really tired and
falling asleep
so i'm like hey man i want you to pull
over so i can drive
because i knocked out yeah i was fresh
yeah because i know i got it i'm going
to drive
and i'm like are you sure yeah no i got
it don't worry yeah so i'm starting to
relax and i'm
i'm i'm thinking like okay well if if he
says he's fine even though i don't feel
it
i was a little nervous but he reassured
me that he was good yeah i started kind
of like dozing off a little bit myself
and then i looked over i [ __ ] you
[ __ ] knot
i see this fool holding the wheel like
this
like the under grips right yeah head
down in his chin into his chest knocked
out
driving knocked out yeah and i go
yo scott wake the [ __ ] up right he looks
and he goes and he just
turns the wheel right when he wakes up
yeah from the left lane all the way to
the right
yeah donuts spun out and we flipped and
flew into a [ __ ] ditch oh my god
and somehow by the grace of god we
dodged
all these cars from the left to the
right lane and didn't hit a single one
and we flipped the flew into a ditch
it was it his car at least it was his
car okay
[ __ ] falls asleep yeah with his head
touching
with his chin touching his chest like
this and we fly into a ditch when i told
him to let me drive and he wouldn't let
me drive right
so i remember after i've never gotten to
in a car accident like that before
so uh we got home and i felt fine and
then i went to go play ball after
after i just flew into a [ __ ] ditch
right yeah i didn't know i had whiplash
oh man so i had whiplash and so but i
was playing ball everything
you know hitting up the boys yeah the
next day i couldn't move my neck
so i was like like paralyzed at my neck
from damn near like two or three weeks i
had no [ __ ] idea
[ __ ] yeah yeah so check it out this was
such a [ __ ] terrible driver
scott yeah this [ __ ] apparently
his parents buys him a brand new camry
after that because that was his parents
camry oh okay within the first month
totals that goes oh my god he totals two
[ __ ] cars
well that's just you don't you don't
deserve to have a car that's what
i'm saying dude and he ended up marrying
one of our our classmates and
that went to riverside too and they have
a kid and everything which i'm pretty
sure i was surprised they didn't [ __ ]
fall asleep on her
this [ __ ] dude well that's
that's pretty much like how john is
you know he's he's uh he's falling
asleep many times while driving
that's hilarious yeah sometimes you got
lucky other times not so much
i just remembered this one time when we
were at a denny's i think we were
drinking
yeah and then we went to go eat at
denny's he fell asleep
while we were eating added denny's
mid-conversation in the sentence yeah
he was just talk he was talking and he
fell asleep dude
that's like you see that [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] time bro that's just hilarious
yeah
how the [ __ ] does it happen to people i
don't i've personally never done it but
i've seen
so many other people do it that it's
just like it's just like a normal thing
once once it's a night of drinking one
time we're at a
in vegas and then uh we were at the club
and then
um we were staying at i think
venetian that's where they have the
cheesecake factory yeah yeah yeah
so the cheesecake factory was uh open
late at night so we went there to eat
and then yeah one of my homies straight
up mid bite
he lifted it up and he just [ __ ] fell
asleep and he's holding
his head
you just sleep i'm like damn dude that's
some skill right there were you there
with a but this book got so plastic
drunk
i saw this fool take a drink
this little drink and he tried talking
at the same time because he was so drunk
he was like hey guys he's
drinking the water and then he's talking
water's coming out of his [ __ ] mouth
i'm like bro drink or talk like both of
the same time
dude no but honestly fatigue fatigue and
alcohol is probably the worst
mix possible you know because there is a
point where people are more tired than
drunk
but then that alcohol is going to have
way more
impact on on you know your your ability
to function at a certain point
and some of the [ __ ] you see people do
is just that's why for me is is so funny
uh not drinking and being soaked because
i see all that [ __ ]
i got so much blackmail materials that's
hilarious dude
it's like all this [ __ ] you did all this
[ __ ] you said you probably don't
remember
dude man riverside was such a [ __ ]
weird time like
i just i had ray over he came over for
dinner one time and then we were talking
about um
i mentioned this one story where you
know how uh there was a certain point
um in our lives where things started
becoming uh really pc
politically kind of just being mindful
of what uh you know
other people go through when we hear
certain words
we've talked about this multiple times
on the podcast yeah we used to use the
word that's gay all the [ __ ] time
right
yeah so i told the story and listen this
is not who i am now
but and i'm a lot more sensitive now but
when you were in the dorms there would
be there were these uh moments where the
ra would
set up these meetings these dorm
meetings where they would talk about
like etiquette right how to properly
address people i heard now like in
college um they
address the fact that you should call
people by the pronouns that they want to
be called like his her
him they that yeah you know all the
other stuff that's
interesting wow yeah in irvine
specifically it's like oh
so i have a nephew out in irvine right
now and he was telling me that the first
day when they moved into their dorms
they were very particular about making
sure that you call people by their
specific pronouns
right and when he raised his hand and
he'd never heard of this because like
sacramento they weren't really talking
about that
i guess and he just and he he went there
and he asked and he goes like
i i don't understand what this is right
yeah and they kind of gave him an
attitude like he was being difficult he
was like no excuse me and he got
mad he goes you can't get mad i don't
know what we're doing right now i don't
know what this is yeah yeah and so he
got upset at the
like the dorm ra because they were
giving him attitude about asking a
[ __ ] question
yeah you know like what the [ __ ] are you
doing like if you're gonna this podcast
is brought to you by
honey no my friends not what you call
your lover but the free
browser extension that saves you money
honey you know how you got that one
asian mom that be saving coupons for
rainy days
well honey is a digital version of that
but she scours the internet for the best
promo codes and applies them for you at
checkout so you get the best deals and
unlike the asian mom she don't beat your
ass you just get the coupons without the
attitude
let me tell you something i don't buy
anything unless honey goes through that
mug first if there's a promo code or
coupon to be used i need it
immediately even on like websites like
amazon and amazon is already crazy cheap
honey gets to work on them prices for
you
nothing in this world feels as good as
saving on deals it's simple if you have
a computer
honey should be on it it's free and
works with whatever browser you use
you can get honey for free today dot at
slash brain that's join honey dot com
slash
brain i set these rules clearly people
are gonna ask what's going on yeah bro
you can't approach it like that yeah you
can't be mad at somebody because they
don't know
and like if they're asking at least
they're taking the time to ask
you know versus being like this is
stupid as hell right because i was that
guy
at the dorm so they they gathered
everybody around and there was this
poster
they wanted to talk about using um gay
as a negative
uh like term right so i remember
it was this poser that was on the wall
and like hey guys
uh when you guys say that something's
kind of whack or dumb what do you guys
say right
and then i was like i'm pretty sure one
of the popular phrases that you guys
have is
that's gay yeah right and they and on
the wall it says don't say that's gay
because you wouldn't say that straight i
looked and i was like that's the gayest
[ __ ] thing i ever heard
everybody started busting up laughing
right but the ra was not happy
kind of gave me a dirty ass [ __ ] look
but i couldn't stop laughing because
that roast was so perfect
so ray told me a story when he was he
had a similar situation
when he went when he was at his dorm and
his ra was doing the whole thing
and they were talking about body
positivity and image and image this is
like what
12 years ago 10 10 11 12 years ago yeah
and so
i guess there was somebody within his
group that's
very good at dishing disses but it's not
very good at taking okay one of those
one of those [ __ ] right so ray
told me this story where they were at
the dorm
and the ra started off by saying like
have you guys
when you guys look at a magazine yeah
proposing this question when you guys
look at a magazine what are the typical
bodies that you see
and what are the typical bodies that you
don't see and i don't know this guy's
name right she
one of the homies were like you don't
see [ __ ] kyle that [ __ ]
this dude kyle apparently he has issues
with his personal body image that nobody
[ __ ] knew yeah
so he just stood up and he was like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you guy just started screaming at
the top of his lungs and it got really
awkward right
and he tried to roast him back by saying
something else he goes well i don't see
any
you know stupid dirty vietnamese people
it's like bro you went racist
yo man like chill but the dude
went off the [ __ ] rails and started
dropping
f-bombs on the [ __ ] in the
middle of the meeting he hit a sore spot
hit a super fat source a sore fat spot
dude i
what i would have liked to see is
actually ray tell this story
that's what i would love to see ray told
me that story i was
dying laughing yeah just because in that
situation when somebody roasts you yeah
don't do that yeah dude just laugh it
off laugh it off
or come back with something else like
they shut the [ __ ] up and start roasting
them back
yeah but don't ever ever in a public
setting
don't do that yeah don't do that type of
[ __ ] yeah yeah but that was so weird
like i i used to always hate people who
could
would always make fun of people but when
they get made fun of they can't laugh
i mean exactly man it's like dude if
you're gonna if you're gonna joke around
you should be able to take a joke too
100
man like you can't expect people to just
be cool and laugh
and and you expect them to be okay with
what you're saying but
moment they rip you a little bit it's
like i [ __ ] dare you
[ __ ] you
i stopped i stopped like roasting people
back as much
because i don't i don't know how to
teeter the line very well like i'm
because i'm
because the way my friends made fun of
each other back at home it was really
hard this is raw
so it was like i didn't i don't know how
to do that
very well so like for example like some
for what i said not too long ago but
one of one of my friends uh recently had
like a falling out with their friends
right
i forgot like this dude started roasting
me yeah and uh damn i wish i could say
your name you little [ __ ] i'm gonna
embarrass the [ __ ] out of you right now
but this dude was like you know making
jokes and he's always good at making
jokes and he started doing like fat
jokes i'm like fat jokes are the easiest
things that you could do and i lost 60
pounds so it's not that funny
so people weren't laughing that much
right and i was like dog why are you
even here like
nobody likes you like you don't have
friends
apparently i had a sore spot right and
it's like yo man that's like too far
and i'm like doug you started it off
yeah you're the one who made the [ __ ]
fat joke yeah i'm over here just telling
you that nobody likes you
dude i was like i'm not even roasting
you these are just facts like why do you
even come to these things
yeah just like it got really [ __ ]
awkward but i just told him like listen
you know what happens when you make fun
of me i don't know that line
yeah so don't start yeah right people
are laughing yeah
at your expense but if you would have
just laughed it would have been okay
he just basically told him he's a
[ __ ] loser yeah and then yes
he had to internalize that i think it
must have hit a sore spot for him or
something like that yeah because nobody
really likes him
you know because he once again he's one
of those friends that likes to make fun
of everybody else at their expense
but can't take it and i'm like you must
have forgot who the [ __ ] i am in this
group yeah you know i mean like
and i don't like doing it like if
somebody roasts me and it's light i just
laugh
because there's no point in me coming
back at you it was like you just made
the group laugh and we all laugh
together
but out of nowhere the dude just started
making fat jokes and i'm like
first of all i've been i've had fat joe
said to me my whole life yeah you better
come prepared yeah like i'm gonna
[ __ ] break
that and you're not even fat though bro
you know what i'm saying it's like
like that's it's a relevant joke if that
joke comes out it's like i've heard fat
jokes my whole life it's like i got and
i know i've
known him for years so i know background
story we know history
so fat jokes are surface level jokes at
this point yeah like i know for a fact
nobody likes you here dude you know go
home you know what my approach now is at
this
age is uh you know cause uh i feel like
uh i'm pretty
uh sharp like my wit is pretty sharp
yeah and so like
i'm quick on my feet and like thinking
um
and so now i'm at a point where if
somebody says something or tries to
clown
it's based on my mood yeah sometimes i'm
just like all right
you know about it yeah i'm gonna just
take it but then other times i'm like
okay i'm gonna obliterate you now
there's that type of mood sometimes but
it's not like my younger days where it's
like automatic rebuttal
um and it's not even like out of uh you
know pettiness or resentment or anything
like that it's just like all right you
clown i gotta clown back that's just the
way it is like
you you basically engaged me in a
sparring session yeah but now it's just
like
uh sometimes i just don't really feel
like uh you know retorting back i'm just
like cause i'm always i think my problem
is is that because i used to get made
fun of so much
i always like to look for an insecurity
and the end the conversation right
because i don't want none of that [ __ ]
because once they get mad like that
that's when it's over right like there
was a buddy of mine who um
he was making fun of me for like stupid
[ __ ] right but
i think i kind of took it the wrong way
because
i just wasn't having it that day you
know you know what i mean and uh he was
kind of making fun of me because like
me and mary will live separate lives and
he was he was kind of alluding to the
fact it's like oh she's probably
cheating on you and [ __ ] like that right
which i didn't really appreciate right
and i just looked at him yeah and i was
like
you're balding yeah and then he got out
he was like what
and then people you know one of the
homies started laughing yeah and i'm
like
dog your hair is so [ __ ] thin you
look like [ __ ] yeah right
that's what you get but once again it's
not really a roast yeah it's just more
like i just figured out what because
this guy used to have thick
ass hair yeah yeah and i saw it and i'm
like bro what the [ __ ] is going on with
your head dude
you made it personal yeah i just called
him homer simpson dude i was like you
got three strands going from one ear to
the other ear
who the [ __ ] are you fooling dude it's
like why would you even joke about
like well that's what i'm saying it's
like i'm like in most of the time i
could take those jokes yeah and you know
and i would come back with something
else but i just wasn't having it that
day and i'm like
you're in the obliteration mode yeah i
was like
oh and you know guys get really
sensitive about their hair yeah and i
was like not only are you bald i was
like bro since high school you got so
[ __ ] fat what do you have going for
you right now
you know you know guys are just going it
doesn't help when the homies just go
oh you know they're like don't [ __ ] with
me right now man
i don't know what's worse to get the oh
or just dead silence you know
like
you took it there yeah i just started
roasting him about his weight yeah how
much weight he's lost
oh how much weight he's gained and
everything and i'm like bro i got this
all [ __ ] day don't do this
but that's the thing it's just like you
know to talk about
your fiance cheating on you especially
because he never met her
yeah it's like hold on a second bro he's
like come on bro like that's
look man what i don't even know why you
gotta joke about something like that
like
come on you you're offending your honor
and her integrity as a person 100 to
suggest that she would even do something
like that yeah then i just kept on
looking up pictures of like bald people
like i just like started swiping
like this kind of looks like you i was
like this kind of looks like you mad you
when he went to the pettiness level
i was doing that [ __ ] all night oh you
know what i ate people did i [ __ ] go
out
dude yeah if i was him i would have just
taken the l and bounce down
you know what i tried i i took a l on it
i'm gonna go home now guys
i don't think i don't do that [ __ ] as
much anymore but it's like
and sometimes just people just catch you
on a bad one and they don't understand
it's like you gotta understand like the
way it's like if you dish it i could
take it
and i'll give it to you ten times back
yeah or if we're both not laughing yeah
then it should stop yeah but
for some reason that joke specific i
think it's because he never met her or
anything else like that yeah so who's
where's the joke here you know it's like
you're not roasting me you're actually
roast you're actually making fun of my
fiance yeah you're not making fun of me
right now right right you're right
so that was like yeah i would uh i would
have uh
been a little bit offended by that too
like yo what the [ __ ] you trying to say
about my fiance bro
it's funny how how weak people are
though in that type of sense it's like
clearly you're balding like we all know
right oh dog he got [ __ ] super
irritated because like uh we were at a
bar
yeah and um you know when these top
lights are down you can really see your
hair light
i was like april let me help you real
quick let me help you real quick though
this light's not helping you out
i was like your hair's so thin i can see
your thoughts
[Laughter]
you know and i don't have like the thick
luscious area but i'm and yet yeah yeah
you're going to get [ __ ] bald one day
too but i'm not nervous
it ain't today i ain't got a bird's nest
on my head right now
dog the picture i wish i still had it
but the picture that i brought up to it
was i was like you know what you look
like right now and it was a picture by
grandpa
just completely bald i was like this
man's 98 years old
and he died this is what you look like
oh
bro i could only imagine [ __ ] that guy
how how the guy was feeling at a certain
point he probably was like man this
sucks
it's just one of those people there's
like a couple of people and you guys
have these group people in your
uh your your circle right and i have a
lot of different circles just because
i've been around so much and you know i
keep a lot of friends for life
but there's people who who like slip
into your group that you don't really
[ __ ] with
they've just been around for a long time
so they're always there
but then i have an issue of of kind of
like
as long as they don't talk to me we're
good yeah but
when you start engaging me in that type
of stuff it's like i actually don't like
you
yeah so it's like this is gonna be a
[ __ ] issue not to mention
you're they're like entering your arena
you know it's like come on man it's what
i do
like roasting is you know there's people
who have roasted me hard
they've gotten me bad i just gotta sit
there laughing i'm like damn actually
gotta hurt my feelings
oh my god i was like you got me bro
that's just [ __ ] good
yeah but once again the people who can't
dish it well that i'm really good
friends with yeah
they can't take it well i just i just
give it to them i'm like oh you got me
because if i say something back it makes
your friendship weird
so i'm just like ah it's whatever dude
yeah and i just say oh you got me
yeah like unless unless they go
unless they go around telling people
that they roast me all the time and i'm
like it's on now dude
when we meet up i'm just going to start
clowning on your [ __ ] ass
it's like keeping records yo my friends
say this is like do you have a list
like you have a list of people that
wrong you i was like i [ __ ] do well
let's get into the genius suggestion of
the day
i feel like people [ __ ] with this stuff
but um let's see
we'll save this one for the next one
okay let's do this one okay uh
no last name let's leave the name out
let's do his name is jordan
hey david uh been a fan for a long time
hope you're doing good and [ __ ]
all right this sounds like a casual
i mean other than a [ __ ] pandemic i
think we're doing okay yeah i hope
you're doing good and [ __ ] yeah
but anyways man uh i'm 22 going on 23
years old
50 tyson and i just
oh my god oh [ __ ]
that has not even like entered my realm
of thoughts
in so long holy [ __ ] 50 tyson original
funniest [ __ ] video oh you're so dope
man
i'm 50 tyson i'm 50 tyson i'm 16.
next year i'mma be remixed
[Laughter]
oh my god i'm gonna have to watch that
when i get home later dog dude
people were calling him at the time
[ __ ] tyson like uh like
that's what they were saying that's
[ __ ] up that's not what i was saying
that's what i
know i remember i remember yeah but
anyways man i'm going i'm 22 going on 23
years old and i feel like i don't
like i don't uh relate to like anyone
around me
i feel like i'm always behind in life in
some way
i've been the black sheep from uh of my
family and friends but i've just been
the funny dude that people want around
like no genuine friendships
okay that's contradictory i come from a
lot of one-sided relationships with
family and past friends for example they
only speak to me if they need something
or if it's convenient for them
the few people i sort of interact with
even say i'm kind of a mysterious guy
because i don't really share much but
it's just because i always feel like
everyone expects me to be the
happy-go-lucky person and i don't share
the stuff i'm dealing with
uh just because i'm used to people not
really being there for me have you ever
gone through this before or something
similar
well it's just a bit of a
self-fulfilling prophecy at that point
though because
if you're unwilling to share if you're
unwilling to
you know expose who you really are how
do you expect people to
know who you really are what i'm saying
a lot of this is contradictory [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] are you saying right
like you know i don't really have deep
relationships and you just said you
don't share anything about yourself yeah
so what the [ __ ] are you saying
i think i think um he's he's uh looking
at it from
uh the wrong perspective i think i think
he feels like
he's already assumed that people won't
accept him for who he is
and how he's really like right and then
so it's automatically a guard put up and
maybe it's even an insecurity like oh
people really know who i am but it's
like bro
that's the risk you got to take if you
want to develop meaningful
relationships and friendships with
people yeah because this honestly is on
you right now if you're
if you're asking for advice to feel i i
don't think this is what you're doing
but uh to feel pity there's no pity
because this is actually your
responsibility
yeah you you literally stated that
people expect you to always be happy
because you don't show them a sad side
that's your how's that their fault yeah
exactly
that that is and so there's obviously
some like
um inner things he needs to work out in
order for him to get to that level
because i mean i could understand
how he has a reservation
about exposing a certain side of him
because like i said maybe he feels
insecure or he doesn't want to be judged
whatever
but he has to overcome that i mean
that's that's that's like an inner
turmoil thing
and so once he gets past that then you
could really see
like who vibes with you on that level
but then if you're constantly putting on
this mask of all
you're just this joking happy-go-lucky
guy yeah and then as a result of that
you think people
expect that from you all the time 24 7.
whose fault is that
exactly exactly so relationship like
friendships too and relationships that
you have is always weird right because
there's a there's definitely
a a balance of how much you can unload
onto somebody right
and i've gone through this really
specifically with a with a few friends
of mine where
um i do understand where he's coming
from like for example there are certain
friends out there that you have
that uh only use you as uh as joe would
like to put it as an emotional tampon
right so whenever's they only hit you up
when [ __ ] goes bad and they want to use
you to [ __ ] vent all that
that's a very exhausting relationship
absolutely so i completely understand
where you're coming from
if that's the only thing that you're
doing with your friendships is you meet
up and like hey man let me tell you how
bad my day is right
then yeah you're gonna be that [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the group that nobody wants to
be around yeah
um specifically i'll tell you about this
person that i know um we were we used to
be really good friends when we came into
la
and mind you i think for me because at
the time i think i had a softer heart
i would listen to a lot of people's
problems in that type of sense
but i didn't kind of take into account
how much it was draining me yeah yeah
i didn't think about that right i was
like yo why am i always so [ __ ] why
am i sad yeah he's like you know why
it's because this grim reaper that i'm
around
it's just [ __ ] sucking the life out
of me this succubus yeah
right and so the the problem that i had
with this uh
individual is that every time i would
meet her up she would complain about how
difficult her life is she would talk
about something about her past that was
so [ __ ] up that was
which is understandable right but every
interaction that i had with her was
about her what was me stuff
yeah now mind you i get it sometimes
when i see them in a very tough and
terrible situation
but this girl specifically gorgeous girl
[ __ ] pretty as [ __ ] right so it's
pretty girl problems yeah yeah and then
on top of that
no matter how great things were
happening for like for example so this
person was was an actress right
and she would book major roles like
really good [ __ ] roles
and uh prior to that a month ago she
would be like i'm not booking anything
and this is the reason why i'm sad
she would book these roles get [ __ ]
buco checks coming in yeah yeah
and then she goes i'm i'm so upset i'm
not booking the right roles that i want
from i'm like okay
just moment just a few months ago you
were barely making ends meet paying your
bills
you're booking these huge things now you
have a surplus of money you're still not
[ __ ] happy and you're still looking
and
every time we have a conversation you're
you're complaining
and so i stopped talking to her for
almost a year because it was [ __ ]
killing me yeah yeah and then i was like
all right cool
maybe we could see each other or
whatever right and that you know i
started i hit her up on text like yo
have you been blah blah blah
um i didn't really decide to meet her up
but i actually saw her outside
of uh in uh los angeles when it first
opened
yeah yeah so i see her haven't seen her
a hot minute and then her family
her family was out uh was here from out
of town the first thing she says right
when i see her hadn't seen her in her
[ __ ] year right
i go yo how have you been i haven't seen
you know while like you know we haven't
we haven't kicked in a long time like
you know we were just talking to each
other yeah and she goes
can i just tell you about my day and i'm
like i looked at it i said i'm gonna go
inside yeah and i just went straight
and i just ignored it i haven't talked
to her in damn near like six years
that's like just perpetual misery and
what do they say about misery misery
loves company and i'm not a miserable
person yeah
exactly exactly people don't understand
that how draining it is to be around
somebody like
you're the bad friend yeah it's like
dude no nobody wants to
constantly be around the [ __ ] whiner
and a complainer and somebody who's
bringing negativity all the time
look as a friend i'm gonna be there for
you when you need me right i'm gonna
give you that kick in the ass if you
need it sometimes
i'm gonna give you just be there as a
listener sometimes give you advice
sometimes
but if you're constantly coming to me
and just [ __ ] complaining and whining
i don't need that type of negativity in
my [ __ ] life yeah you figure your
[ __ ] out and get your [ __ ] together
you're a [ __ ] adult
you know um and so like i completely get
it man if i had
i mean i've had um i'm not gonna say
maybe to that extent
where somebody's just constantly
complaining but i've had my
you know fair share of dealing with
whiners and complainers and it's like
at a certain point you recognize dude
this person's gonna complain no matter
what it doesn't matter what it is
no matter what they like you said
something that they complained about
before
got better but they find a new thing to
complain about now something is
always wrong and it's like if something
is always wrong
maybe something's wrong with you yeah
you know what i mean because they
they're not looking at things through a
gracious lens right there's no gratitude
cup is half empty for them very
pessimistic all the [ __ ] time yeah
and i so i understand when you feel like
you might be that person
but there are times where you know if a
majority of times you're a
happy-go-lucky happy person
yeah then yeah you're allowed to vent
and kind of process your thoughts with
other people
honestly like if you guys haven't gone
through therapy that's it's it's almost
like having an unbiased best friend
but they have you know an expertise and
they help you like filter through your
thoughts
that's what a lot of therapy that people
get is through their friendships like
they do get to vent to each other
sometimes
yeah yeah as long as like the reason why
you're they're around you isn't for you
to just constantly use and abuse that
emotional part of your relationship and
then toss them aside
so i think like he's being a little
paranoid yeah if
he uh jordan man if you want people to
know the real you
you got to show people the real you and
you cannot
uh be scared of like being judged for it
or or you know
being looked at i mean listen man if you
got some strange [ __ ] quirks if don't
like
automatically you know first time you
meet somebody be like can i suck your
dirty toes
you know what i mean like if that's the
real you bro there's
there's going to be a little bit of
greasing before you can get to that but
if it's other [ __ ] man like because you
really do sound like a pessimist like
when i read this stuff you says i've
been the black sheep of my family and
friends but i
but i've just been the funny dude that
people wanted around that first of all
that doesn't make any sense how can you
be the black sheep and then everybody
wants you around
yeah i mean black sheeps are usually an
outcast outcast they don't want you
around yeah like they hate your guts
yeah yeah so i i don't know exactly what
he means by that
but um i can see
like from from a standpoint of
people expect you to be a certain way
because that's all you've shown them i
can understand that
but again that's on him you know and i
guess like i mean
once again like you haven't set these
boundaries and you haven't really
defined your friendships and
relationship with these people and
that's your personal responsibility yeah
yeah
and i know because he mentioned one part
that people only uh call them when they
need something
which i i get dude there was a dude in
high school that i knew just like that
and i [ __ ] hated him yeah like he
he's one of the people that comes into
the group that every time we have a
function
i have to stay away from him because i
know he's that person like yeah
so the last time i actually spoke to him
through my phone was uh like quite a few
years back
and it's because you know as you get
older you your your
level of [ __ ] or the amount of
[ __ ] that you could deal with
becomes really really small right right
so i haven't taught this guy in a hot
minute and hits me up he goes yo brother
how have you been
like how's life and i just literally
wrote back to him what the [ __ ] do you
want
what do you want and lo and behold he
was asking me for a favor
it's like nah there's no favors here
yeah i haven't talked to you in a long
time we don't have that rapport yeah
there's none of that [ __ ] yeah what i
would have preferred is if you just came
straight up and asked me right i still
would have rejected you yeah but i would
have hated i would
respect it i would have respected it
yeah i wouldn't have hated you as much
yeah you know
so yeah i i understand what that's like
there's a lot of people in this in these
cases especially when you
start doing really well for yourself
people you'll you'll start to see people
come out the woodwork yeah yeah you know
it's a odd place to be in yeah but the
the thing to take away from this jordan
is that you got to not be scared to to
be the real you man you gotta if you
want people to see and you wanna feel
accepted for who you are
that first step is on you you gotta take
it and basically
it's on you to show people that and from
that point on hopefully you can meet
people
who are down with with all of you know
you're the full spectrum
of your your personality and who you are
versus just this funny and easygoing guy
um but i mean he might be i mean 22-23
i think when you're at that age it's
like
sometimes i felt when i was younger i i
kind of wore too many uh
too many hats right so uh
i i was just i would tend to mold myself
to what other people wanted me to be
yeah just because i would try to make
them feel comfortable
um which is a terrible idea listen we
all
i don't know what the terms like code
switching or some [ __ ] like that we'll
change the way that we speak our
mannerism and stuff
to to a certain extent you know just so
you could be comfortable with the crowd
to kind of feel things out
yeah everybody does that stuff but if
you're changing the the core of who you
are just so you can mold into another
group
yo that [ __ ] is [ __ ] exhausting yeah
yeah it's too tiring
yeah yeah but i mean i feel like it's a
process that
certain people need to go through to to
learn like who they truly are what they
what their identity is um other people
you know get the grasp of it earlier but
yeah it's a process for everyone and so
22
23 i feel like he still has a lot to
learn and go through
yeah man you'll get to that point one
day like me where you're super jaded you
don't give a [ __ ]
like you know you gotta this is the most
liberating [ __ ] time of my life where
it's just like i don't give a [ __ ] man
uh i did i did um uh i did a favor for
somebody recently um
yeah i wish i could say names it'll make
things a lot easier i'm going to say
fake names so i did a favorite for my uh
for my friend jackie right
um so uh because of my online persona
uh this favor that i did for her she she
mentioned that one of her friends
uh talked to her through like dms or
something like that they're like oh you
got to meet david so
right and she goes yeah it's actually uh
one
his fiance is actually a really good
friend of mine and so you know he helped
me out with a couple of things
and this person wrote like uh he's not
really as nice as he says he is right
and i'm like well she mentioned this to
me she goes yeah i got a little
irritated when that person said that
about you and i'm like
i was like listen if i gave a [ __ ] about
what everybody thought about me
or if i had a dollar for every time
somebody says negative about me i'd be
[ __ ]
rich out of my mind yeah i was like i
was like you got to think about it like
this
if this person i'm living in this
person's head rent [ __ ] free
yeah i don't know this person yeah this
person saw me on a couple of videos i
probably said something very
you know disparaging towards that person
or maybe i wrote a negative comment
towards them yeah
and now that individual had to go out of
their way
to ask you if i'm a really nice person
in real life because they hate my guts
right and then she was like yeah i was
like sitting there i had to defend you
saying like no you're like one of the
nicest people i've met you're very
cordial you know you're a version of who
you are in your videos but you're very
nice
i was like you don't have to do all that
all you have to tell them is [ __ ] off
yeah
if you want to meet him yeah come say
something to him yeah simple
you know what you mean but like that's
the thing too when you start to realize
when you're who you are starts to
irritate somebody else's spirit
you that's on them that is not on you at
that point
you're just being your [ __ ] self yeah
i'm at this point now in my life where
you will get there too eventually
not to say that you're not an
unempathetic person not to say that
you're not going to care about how you
carry yourself
and how you come across to other people
you got to have sense you gotta have sex
you have to have tech yeah these are all
there too right
but the fact that i i'm not in a point
in my life where i feel like after
that person told me this information am
i gonna go back and say oh [ __ ] i should
probably change the way i do my videos
i should probably change the way i say
things yeah [ __ ] that suck my [ __ ]
nuts
yeah if i'm living in your head
rent-free that's your problem you need
to evict me out of there
yeah no that's that's always been me too
man since i was young i never gave a
[ __ ] what
anybody thought about me it's like you
got a problem with me that's too [ __ ]
bad
man nobody said you got to be friends
with me nobody said you gotta like me
[ __ ] yeah i never attacked you
personally yeah
if my spirit irritates you maybe
sometimes
and that's fine it's justified that you
don't like me then yeah you're going
bald man
but whatever the case is yeah like i
just i really don't give a [ __ ] what
people think
about me um outside of the people that i
care and love for
you know if uh if somebody that i love
is telling me oh i'm hurting them in a
certain way or i'm causing some sort of
like problem
then i'll listen you know but if it's
like some rando or like some
acquaintance
i don't give a [ __ ] you could suck my
dick
that's really what it is when you get to
that point in your life where you could
tell somebody freely to suck your dick
yeah that's a great
it's liberating yeah right because when
you're younger you just want to make
sure that you fit in you don't want to
like stir the pot or nothing
and you're probably in that right now
you're overthinking these situations
you're like oh what if i open too much
are they going to think i'm overbearing
yeah if i'm not happy nobody wants to be
my friend yeah bro shut the [ __ ] up
like [ __ ] you are so [ __ ] annoying
right now dude
i'm surprised that you're the black
sheep and everybody wants to be around
that makes no [ __ ] sense what the
[ __ ] are you talking about dude
i think maybe what he's saying is like
i don't i'm completely going off
assumption here but
when he's saying he's the black sheep
maybe like his
interests are different from what the
status quo is you know like things that
most people would do and say or whatever
he
kind of strays from that i don't know it
almost sounds like a self-proclaimed
title
rather than like the family outcasting
him as the
yeah yeah you're the black sheep of the
family your [ __ ] disappointment
you know like you're a piece of [ __ ]
he's like eminem in the bathroom
i feel like this is a lot of this is
like kind of coming from within
feelings yeah these feelings are coming
from within insecure whatever but you'll
be
you'll be so surprised like the power of
just like positive thought yeah that
should sound like some hippie [ __ ] but
yeah
uh i think when we define it like that
it sounds a little weird but i'm
definitely at that wavelength of just uh
wishing good things to happen and it
happens right
um there was we talked about on jk news
where they were doing like that
there's probably japanese people that
was doing this dumb study but
it was like japanese people would be
studying some stupid [ __ ] all kinds of
crazy questions
i love it but it was like uh speaking to
like these ice forms and the ice
particles and when you would um
look at it under a microscope when you
would say negative things like the
the ice structures were all [ __ ] up
yeah but when you said positive things
it was like these beautiful [ __ ]
structures
now before they were looking through the
microscope were they also taking some
acid
and they were high as [ __ ] yeah it was
like well step one
drop some acid dude yeah
that sounds like that's some crazy [ __ ]
yeah that's some crazy [ __ ] right there
but there's like
i'm not sure we got to look this up but
there was like studies where uh they
were talking about if you
s you spoke kindly to plants like they
would even grow better or something like
that
like that because they're living beings
or something like that yeah i'm curious
to see how that happens because i spoke
really kindly to my tomato plants and
that [ __ ] only gave me two tomatoes
[ __ ]
piss me off dude um but you know there's
also that uh the idea right like even if
you're in a [ __ ] mood or not feeling
good if you smile
the act of smiling right will make you
feel better yeah
i mean i'm pretty sure there were
studies done on that too they do that
with dogs too when you when you train
dogs who
are are timid and scared when you walk
with your dog they'll ask you to lift
your dog's tail up
because the the motor function of of
that of having a tail up is a sign of
them being
um secure and happy and also confident
yeah so dogs who are scared they'll walk
them and they'll hold their tail up and
it helps them
yeah yeah i would just helicopter it's
like come on buddy
let's go yeah man uh i think it's hard
for us to also kind of look at ourselves
from an outside lens right for sure for
sure because we
for as far as i know he says he's like
the bell of the ball like he's like the
super
social guy and everybody loves him but
what if you come into the room and
i see you in real life yeah and they're
like yo this [ __ ] guy jordan's
has here again of michael jordan but
can't even touch a basketball who knows
you might be that guy yeah i mean
that is a good point though you really
do have to try to be honest with
yourself
of who you are and how you're perceived
you know
um because that's that's definitely uh i
think a healthy step towards like
you finding your community right if
you're
if you're trying to be somebody that
you're not you're not ever gonna find
your community
right and so like if your perception is
oh people
only want to see the happy-go-lucky
joking jordan
right then they like they don't know you
so they they can't be the community
you're seeking because they don't know
what other part of jordan exists you
know
and maybe those group of friends are
probably not the one for you
yeah for example i've talked about
multiple times in this podcast like i
wanted to be around like thugs i did not
belong there
i was a very obviously odd person yeah
you want to talk about a feeling of not
belonging that's me
dude i'm over here just in the corner
just like oh where am i
like why am i here in hindsight you're
like why'd i put myself through so much
stress and anxiety
listen i got so many stories about being
in these dangerous situations where
if i wish somebody just had a camcorder
and you see all these people just like
bandana
colored and i'm just sitting here just
with glasses and this and a split
haircut just like like who the [ __ ] is
this loser here and i'm like
look i'm with this dude you know and i'm
just sitting there quiet not saying
anything at all
yeah and i didn't belong there if you
want to talk about being a black sheep i
guess i was the black sheep of that
group
yeah you know what you just mentioned um
reminded me of a thought that i had
a long time ago but the whole you know
you said if
if there was a camcorder recording of
like you know
i had an idea because now we're in a
time and space
where it's realistic very realistic to
be able to document your life in real
time
right so i had this idea of like what if
there's somebody out there
who's documenting their life in real
time right now and the plan is
once they get to an age where like all
the kind of um
their youth is gone and all the fun
things that they did when they were
younger
they watch it back in real time oh wow
you know what i mean so like when you
turn 70 you're like you know what
i want to relive my 20s and so i'm gonna
watch in real time what my day-to-day
was like in the 20s
there'd be a lot of jacking
i think i said this on jk news but i
remember one time i was so
[ __ ] horny like and then i had to go
to my parents store right
i was at the beauty supply store right
and this [ __ ] fine ass girl came in
with a fat ass and everything right
and just like i'm in high school right
now my dick would get hard over anything
right like to the point where sometimes
a dude would walk in my dick with your
heart and i'd be like
i'm like oh watch my dick card right now
because i know those two are separate
things
they don't work my diction's hard for no
reason yeah but they were like i would
just be chilling
and then this one [ __ ] fine ass girl
came in with a fat ass
and then this boner would not go away oh
man it was
it was pissing me off yeah yeah cause
even after she left yeah i was i wasn't
thinking about it at all but my [ __ ]
dick was still hard and i just had to
sit sit down on the chair and cross my
legs and the art of hiding the boner
during your try to hide this boner and
there's only one little thin path that
would go all the way to the back into
the bathroom
so i had to wait for my mom to go help a
customer or there had to be one customer
there
that my mom would trust so i didn't have
to be there yeah and so i had to [ __ ]
wait and then she got down and she went
over to go help the customer i was like
i'm gonna go to the back to go to the
bathroom
and i went to the bathroom i was like i
have to jack off
there's only one way there was only way
to solve this problem and that dingy
little bathroom at my parents store
at a beauty supply store i [ __ ]
whacked off
with the fury and i remember that's the
first time i jacked off standing up
oh wow i've never jacked off standing up
before yeah right
and after that i was like i'll just jack
off in the shower like it's such an easy
cleanup
you had an epiphany yeah it just started
unfolding this whole whole new world
there's a latin moment a whole new world
just jacking off in the shower open your
eyes
yeah but i just remember i was just
whacking off in the bathroom
hurry up hurry up the customer's here so
i had a [ __ ] jack off as fast as
possible
and i just nutted right in the toilet
the fact that you
felt like i need to do this right i
i feel so horny that i need to do this
right now i don't think i've ever had a
moment like that
my [ __ ] boner wouldn't go away it
wouldn't go it was like a solid like
i mean for me it felt like 10 minutes
but i'm pretty sure it was probably
three or four minutes
but you know it just it wouldn't listen
you just had a throbbing [ __ ] man yeah
that needed to be released
i still remember that ass till this
[ __ ] goddamn day dude
speaking of touching genitalia how about
that rudy giuliani
um as some of you guys might know borat
2 is coming out
and you know borat always does these
interviews with
real people and they get them he always
finds a way to get them into these
precarious situations
and he manages to manage to get him to
say and do things that they
normally might not do and in this genius
yeah in this uh scenario with uh rudy
giuliani apparently
his the actor that's playing his
daughter
was posing as a news reporter for
a conservative um news outlet
and then so hold on let me let me let me
pull up and re
because there was an article written
about this [ __ ]
okay so um in the film released on
friday
uh the former new york mayor and current
personal attorney to donald trump is
seen reaching into his trousers
and apparently touching his genitals
while reclining on the bed in the
presence of the actor playing borat's
daughter
who is posing as a tv journalist what
the
explain to me what the [ __ ] is happening
so let me read the rest of it for you
so following an obsequious interview for
a fake conservative news program
the pair retreat at her suggestion for a
drink to the bedroom of a hotel suite
which is rigged with concealed cameras
after she removes his microphone
giuliani 76 can be seen lying back on
the bed
fiddling with his untucked shirt and
reaching into his trousers trousers
they are then interrupted by borat who
runs in and says she's 15 she's too old
for you
oh my god that's gonna be so [ __ ]
damning dude oh my
in the middle of wait election you know
wait how the [ __ ] how did they get this
recorded i don't know man and how is it
released without the getting sued
i have no [ __ ] idea but that's what
i'm saying like dude
everything that that sasha baron cohen
releases as these characters you always
ask that
how the [ __ ] did this get released is he
married
i'm pretty sure he's married yeah i'm
pretty [ __ ] sure he's married he
wasn't getting his dick sucked he was
jacking off to her
in the room so he it's like i don't know
exactly if he was masturbating but it
looked like he was trying to get himself
going you know
old people [ __ ] i can't relate to it but
he had a conversation with his dick like
please don't fail me now
please you start slapping it come on
come on come on come on
we gotta do it come on that's [ __ ]
funny dude yes i can i can't wait to see
boris
dude man if you know what's so
interesting about that stuff it's a
comedy but that does
show i don't want to say like corrupt
politics but it's more like
just how weird these [ __ ] people are
man people in power are [ __ ] weird
man yeah dude what is it about them is
it because you guys couldn't get [ __ ]
when you were younger and so you just
have to do it now look what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you man
you know i think there's a whole
spectrum of reasons
of why they are the way they are i mean
for
i think celebrities i think it's at a
certain point
they they start getting weird maybe
sexually in their taste sexually because
it's too easy
yeah you know if you're a dude you get a
straight dude you're getting [ __ ] all
the time if you're a straight female
you're getting dick
all the time anytime you want it and
it's so easy to come by at a certain
point
he's like you know what standard [ __ ]
and standard dick is boring to me now
yeah
i wanna i want some freaky [ __ ] yeah i
wanna
maybe i wanna explore a butthole of the
other gender you know
like you know what i mean that's [ __ ]
weird man yeah i'd be hearing stuff
about
like celebrity musicians and talking
about how they
they speci and this is like people in
like the studio circuit
and there's constant rumors about them
being you know what are fluid bisexual
or whatever these are like married
married like dudes and women and it's
like they've gotten like for example in
the most crudest ways possible some of
these guys are so [ __ ] popular that
they can literally get any woman that
they want
that out of nowhere they just like
what's dick like you know
and then they're like let me just see
what it's like to get [ __ ] in my ass
yeah and they just start doing and then
from that one that's like a gateway to
other weird shirts right right so
i can imagine with some of these
celebrities what happens to their psyche
when they get bored with just
regular [ __ ] dick or vagina yeah and
they want to try weird [ __ ]
yeah that's why you have some of these
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] insane
dude yeah
and also i think it's a reason why some
of these celebrities
uh come off so rapey because like to
them
it's easy you know what i mean like they
don't even have
like bare minimum effort and it's all
like almost a given
that it's going to happen but then
sometimes you're going to meet people
like what the [ __ ]
nah not going to suck your dick right no
[ __ ] yeah
is it what you mean you're not going to
suck yeah
yeah you don't know who i am yeah so i
know exactly who the [ __ ] you are i'm
gonna [ __ ] sue your ass
i know who the [ __ ] you are you [ __ ]
pervert yeah that's hilar dude borat is
a genius man
i had this um well let me tell you about
this so
i at a certain point i was pitching a
lot of show ideas right
so if you guys ever pitch a show idea
i'm not saying that this should be the
best advice but this was a
this is advice that was given to me
anyways when you're kind of pitching
comedy shows
studios and studios kind of have to be
mindful of advertisement money and
everything else and like
so when you kind of shoot for these
crazy uh ideas you shoot for the stars
and then you let them chop it down to
whatever you want to do yeah so i this
is like very interesting
so i had an idea that was inspired by
borax okay and i'm like okay cool so you
guys already know i had this uh
this character called kim jong-il so kim
jong-il
is essentially a north korean defector
right
leader of north korea and he wants to
come to america to to do regular people
[ __ ]
but he still does stuff in his north
korean dictator way so it's not really
normal people's [ __ ] yeah
he just he just threatens people and
says that you know i'm the best at
everything and they disagree
yeah so i have this this i had this idea
with a buddy of mine named deepak and i
still kind of want to create this if
somebody is willing to do it
but it would require for there to be
actors and there's full
um and non-actors in there so i wanted
to do stuff where
uh it's a series where this guy kim
jong-il goes around
and he wants to be the number one at
everything but but he's learning how to
be a human and learning about uh
american customs so for example the
first episode
and i pushed this in a meeting and
people were half the room was laughing
the other half was mortified
yeah so i was like well that's how you
know it's good though exactly yeah i was
like so this is this is what the idea is
right so i kind of give them the premise
about who kim jong-il is and people are
laughing they're like oh this is really
interesting
so the first episode he's going to be a
a woman self-defense teacher
right people are kind of smiling and i
was like but
he's not going to teach women how to
defend themselves he's going to teach
men how to defend themselves against a
woman who knows self-defense
so because he's trying to so he's using
them as a property
he's looking for an open market yeah
he's like oh well
so he's he's a self the best teacher for
rapists yeah
so like he basically comes in and
there's like a sign that says
that says uh no means maybe that's like
the first oh
my god he has a toolkit where one tool
kit
is a jar of of cold milk and the other
one is pliers and the pliers is to crush
the rape whistle
and the milk is for pepper spray so you
can put it in your eyes and so
that was this and literally half the
room is dying laughing
and the other room is just kind of
mortifying right yeah but i'm trying to
explain them and they're like well
what's
what's the takeaway from this i was like
well the takeaway is that he's he's not
successful at this yeah
so there's half-planted actors and
actresses some of them actors are really
into it's all the males they're like
they're taking like serious notes yeah
but there's also women in the
self-defense class and i think it's an
actual women's self-defense class
and so we're recording them just
mortified yeah yeah about the whole
situation
but then afterwards like the thing is
it's like i'm not saying rape is okay
obviously yeah so the thing is like
through this whole course
these people are freaking out and
getting mad and he starts to learn like
oh i can't just run business with the
way that i want so he starts to learn
how to be a normal human being
yeah because he can't understand why
people are mad yeah and that's how he
starts to
learn about how to be a functioning
member of society by [ __ ] up in all
these situations
the the journey of king jong-il
exactly so you're trying to you're
trying to humanize this this uh
this terrible leader dictator this
dictator that doesn't know any better
yeah
and so um that's what that's that's what
the idea was and almost got picked up
but
it was like during some weird times when
uh north korea was uh
hacking everybody so they didn't want to
touch any of it but that [ __ ] was
interesting just watching the because
they have comedian writers there they
have comics who are right yeah they're
dying laughing yeah
right but then some of the execs are
just like you see them visibly sweating
yeah yeah like uh i don't know if we
could do i was like but
come on yeah a [ __ ] north korean
dictator that comes to open up a woman's
self-defense class to teach rapists how
to defend themselves against women
i was like that is ridiculous yeah
that's [ __ ] ridiculous yeah and by
the way too just to paint it like he's
getting his ass whooped throughout the
whole thing
none of this is working every you know
all these guys get [ __ ] up by the
women so
i i know how to navigate it right like i
don't want people to walk away thinking
like oh this is
okay yeah i'm making fun of these type
of people right
people who are so stupid and aloof yeah
yeah so like i tried to pitch that idea
and it did not go through
well the the fact that you got the
reaction like that though were
so polarizing because that's what you
want
that would be so ridiculous that you
have no choice but to
find comedy in it you know what i mean
that when i when i pitched that idea
like i still want to make it till this
day yeah i'm putting it out right now
yeah i mean you might see it one day hey
come on support this kim jong-il
i have a pilot episode that i shot
really um but it just didn't turn out
that way oh okay uh we were trying to
pitch it it didn't work out yeah
but because nobody wanted to do this
idea because it's very touchy
but in the pilot you also had half and
half like
actors and i know this one was just
awful so
this one that that episode was him
trying to be an actor
and then i have this whole it was like a
mockumentary style type of thing yeah so
so the spin was a little different okay
but this other one that i have was just
supposed to be like almost like found
footage like security
you can't see [ __ ] it looks real as [ __ ]
which it is it's like half real have not
yeah yeah you're trying to fool this
audience yeah but i wanted to try that
out super bad
the the memory that always sticks out to
me with the kim jong-il
is when you slap that dude in the face
are you talking about my boy chris
i don't know his name but that [ __ ] oh
man that [ __ ] had me rolling with that
because it was so unexpected it still
makes me laugh till this day yeah you
know the funny thing is i
don't think i even told him i was gonna
slap his reaction looks like his dude oh
my that
that [ __ ] i think i just slapped the
[ __ ] out of him and he was like you
gotta include that clip in this
in this podcast bro i love that
character dude because the character is
such a terrible human being yeah exactly
he's such a terrible person
yeah and the fact that um
it's like a different angle because he's
coming from
i mean first of all north korea is the
hermit kingdom yeah they're closed off
completely
his owner's purity yeah absolute
ignorance and on top of that he has
just unquestioned power and authority
assassins everywhere you can't really do
anything about it and then for that to
even
have some sort of restriction even the
slightest amount
that's a whole new foreign territory for
him you know and
even then when uh i started humanizing
him a little bit because he
even no matter how much power he has
he's still a little [ __ ] when it comes
to his wife that's when arden came on
for that episode where i had a
z in there yeah and i thought z had the
hardest time dude we had to do so many
tastes because he couldn't stop laughing
yeah
because he would crack up i would crack
up yeah yeah yeah cause i'm just abusing
the [ __ ]
i remember you're like kicking him yeah
that [ __ ] was hard to get through but
i missed doing sketches though yeah well
hopefully uh somebody sees this out
there and uh you know throws a little
money
hey pick it up dude let's make it happen
dude i'll do some funny ass [ __ ] yeah
but people have to not be scared
that's the thing like yeah you got to be
definitely willing to take some
criticism for that [ __ ] you know like uh
cause i'm not scared to put content like
that i'll defend that [ __ ] all the way
down yeah it's pretty simple
well it that also reminds me of kind of
like joaquin
phoenix's project when he was trying to
be a rapper right
people didn't know that that was a a
character he was playing
yeah it was a project between him and
casey affleck right oh yeah yeah yeah
and then so he went full method on that
[ __ ] and he was in that character
on talk shows it's like out in public
and then
later on it came to light that yeah this
was character yeah
but at the time people were like is this
a [ __ ] joke or is this guy for real
and they're like oh my god this guy is
for reals right now yeah he's really
serious about giving up acne and being a
rapper
and then it was so [ __ ] polarizing i
didn't even know about this
oh you didn't you didn't know about i
didn't know about this bro joaquin
phoenix went into this like
hip-hop mode and then he was like i'm
gonna be a rapper i'm giving up acting
and then he went on the letterman show
to talk about it and he was being super
[ __ ] awkward
you know very socially and letterman
didn't know what to do with about it
either
yeah because he was like is this guy
playing a character
or is he for reals right now but that's
the thing he didn't reveal it until like
i think a year later
after the fact and they were making a
mockumentary
yeah so that that was that's another
spin on that type of [ __ ]
they knew exactly who he was but he was
playing a character and
the whole time yeah didn't tell anybody
damn that's [ __ ] these actors are
nuts
i'm telling you the best actors are the
most [ __ ] psychotic human beings i've
ever met yeah
walking phoenix they're weird incredible
[ __ ] actor you know
did you who was the actor heath ledger i
heard he was playing
um he was in method the whole time when
he was doing the joker yeah this would
be at a cafe
just pick the joker and he would scare
people like he would freak people the
[ __ ] out
because he wouldn't break characters why
he's so serious yeah he's like acting
like the weird switchy paranoid
joker that he's playing in the film yeah
but he's at a [ __ ] cafe eating a
croissant
like come on dog like chill for a second
but he got [ __ ] up i what um jack
nicholson was kind of warning him about
that character he's like hey you can't
you can't live in that character for too
long yeah it's gonna [ __ ] yeah
you know so i i there was like a lot of
kind of like these um
stories and stuff that came out of how
like that's the role that drove him to
commit suicide or overdose
and whatever but um just
uh just as much evidence came out to
counter that as well
yeah so it's it's it's like more of
adding to
kind of the uh the story of it it makes
it seem like
it kind of came out of nowhere yeah yeah
uh it makes it seem a lot more
mysterious and like oh that role must
have really been that there's roles that
[ __ ] people up though because i'm sure
remember a breaking bad who's who is the
main character the young guy the drug
dealer
um jesse jesse pinkman yeah so jesse
uh malcolm in the middle is dad what's
his name um
what the character's name or the actor
both brian cranston and walter white
okay so brian cranston yeah
i guess the the the guy who's playing
jesse
uh he was doing a lot of method acting
where i read this but he was doing it
too much to the point where i think he
was at a bar and he was still in that
weird like paranoia
yeah [ __ ] yeah and then like brian
crasson was telling him to cut that [ __ ]
out yeah he's like
this is too much yeah this is just very
unnecessary yeah you're kind of getting
you're kind of taking this overboard
like you don't need to do it like as an
actor cut that [ __ ] out because i guess
it's not really healthy for your psyche
or some [ __ ] like that well at least he
had something like an experienced
respected actor to like kind of
pull him out of it yeah yeah be like hey
that's uh you're crossing the line
but some of these other actors like they
just go full hundred percent
you know because i do understand what
it's like because when i was on on goo
like justin kind of
he didn't make me do method but he kind
of made me live in the character for a
long time
when he was coaching my acting it
actually made me into a very angry
person like it uh
because of the scenes that we were
shooting and it kind of leaked on this i
got so [ __ ] madness
well mind you it was deserved because
justin pissed me off
broke a table i smashed his [ __ ]
chair yeah i started
[ __ ] wrapping my fist into this
[ __ ] fence yeah i
smashed the [ __ ] fence yeah i sat
down and i was like
this [ __ ] role's [ __ ] me up right
now you know like
i don't think if i was normal yeah like
this i wouldn't have gotten that mad
i i don't see how it doesn't affect a
normal human being
you're living with this character every
night for [ __ ] two months straight
you could only compartmentalize so much
yeah you know
i like shaved my head earlier i gained
weight i started dressing like the
character every day and i'm like
this is exhausting that's why i would
love to spend the day with somebody like
daniel day lewis who's been doing
method acting his whole [ __ ] life
it's like a crazy person yeah i would
like to just have a conversation with
this guy daniel dave lewis if you had to
play a gay dude he'd be sucking dick for
two years
i wouldn't doubt it i wouldn't doubt it
i've deep throated 17 [ __ ] in the last
year
it's like you didn't have to do that
you're just playing you're playing a gay
person yeah you you taking it to extreme
like gay people don't even suck dick
that much dude yeah
like it doesn't work that way man
respect respect
he's one of the best actors of our
generation for sure daniel davis baby
yeah
you know what's weird um damn i wonder
if i should bring this up for another
podcast topic we'll skip this we'll talk
about another one just because
it might get a little [ __ ] heavy
but when i when i wanted to be an actor
yeah um i think like
i definitely look towards a lot of
actors like that like daniel day lewis
just because to see somebody
do something where it's that convincing
blows my mind yeah like you're convinced
even people people don't understand some
actors are so [ __ ] good
they play a villain so well you you say
you hate the actor right but you don't
hate the actor you actually hate the
character yeah exactly
that's how [ __ ] good they are yeah
you know because i've i've done that too
but remember that kid who played lucious
uh uh draco malfoy
he stopped acting because people were
bullying him who draco malfoy from harry
potter
i never watched harry potter bro you're
going to hell dude you've never watched
harry
potter i've never i never got into it it
was like what's wrong with you man yeah
it was uh it was like uh
uh i i think i was too old uh by the
time it really started getting popular
for everybody i know it's for everybody
but like i looked at it as like
ah that's not my cup of tea you know i
just watched harry bought harry potter
for the first time during the quarantine
i'm surprised she would be she looks
like somebody who would be like into
that time because she's scared of it
because it's like creepy
it's like magic and you know other stuff
yeah she doesn't like creepy [ __ ] like i
tell you what though there is a harry
potter video game coming out though she
looks pretty dope
i'm not even a harry potter fan no you
can't play until you watch it dude all
right well i'm not everybody watches it
[Laughter]
never saw this i've never seen it that's
[ __ ] nice well dude harry potter
land's only fun if you know what's going
on
that so people say look when i was in uh
london
i went to the harry potter store to get
my because my sister's a big harry
potter fan
um i was there and i'm like yo these
people are on some [ __ ] bro they're like
they're [ __ ] hardcore with them yeah
you
know
yeah and i'm like i'm trying to get
something for her and i have no [ __ ]
clue
what there's like different schools and
like and i'm like
yo which one's the villain and which
one's the good guys there's no good or
bad guy dude he's just depends on the
school
i just know harry potter uh daniel
ratcliffe i know that guy
i know he's harry potter and then you
got that no nose [ __ ]
i just know that's the creepy dude and i
assume he's the villain just because the
way he looks
so i'm like trying to get my sister [ __ ]
and i have no clue and there's a time
difference so i can't even like hit her
up you know
and i'm there and there's i first of all
i had to wait in line to get in there
and i'm like i can't believe these
[ __ ] are waiting in line
to pay money like you're waiting in line
willingly to pay money give them money
fandom like star wars people have fandom
you know because jk rowling's like the
most wealthiest person
yeah ever in britain or london yeah so
it was it was definitely
interesting to see and i'm like man
people are really about this harry
potter
and i remember i recorded a because they
got that cart going into the wall what's
that [ __ ] called oh so that's when you
go into the train station so you can go
into the
yeah and an energy world i recorded a
guy because he was so into it but this
dude was like 30 something years old
oh well that's around that makes sense
if he's 30 something years old and it
was around his time
okay okay yeah and it was just cracking
me up because he's like he was so into
it it was so genuine
you know i mean i didn't like clown on
the dude or anything that would have
been me fool
you right into the harry potter well i i
didn't read all the books but i love the
movies
okay when i was at the men's warehouse
we had the full dvd set
and that's the only thing we could watch
so i watched that film from front to end
like a million times you know what maybe
i'll give it a chance man maybe i'll
i'll try one
oh in the first two but then the third
fourth fifth and sixth one that's when
it's
it's like it gets real cause it becomes
more dark okay so i'll give you an
example of like
uh me giving something a try when i
wasn't really into it lord of the rings
right
like you know laura brings us [ __ ] dude
i know i know and then so like i was
never into it but i got a friend who's
into it and he's like hey you just gotta
check it out
so i ended up watching all three they're
long too they're like yeah
super [ __ ] long and i got out of it
and i'm like yeah i could have done
without that i didn't need that in my
life
you know i'm so good though no i could i
could see why people will get into it
and and like it's not that i'm not into
the fantasy [ __ ] at all
some some of it is appealing to me but
just because you watch game of thrones
yeah
how you not like lord of the rings
that's the thing so that's what i'm
saying like lord of the rings didn't you
know what because there's no [ __ ]
[ __ ] and tits in that that's why
maybe because i remember the only
because i couldn't get into game of
thrones because i watched the first
season i hated it i was like this is so
[ __ ] predictable
yeah i was like i'm over this [ __ ] i'm
glad you mentioned lord of the rings
though because what you're mentioning
right now of an actor quitting
is joffrey the same thing that was his
main
like first time getting a main role um
and
he basically so many people hated on him
right how good he is yeah that's how
good he
but if you listen to this guy speak i
mean first of all he's really
intelligent but he's like actually
kind of meek and and like you know guys
yeah
i was and he quit acting he's just like
i'm gonna focus on studies because they
[ __ ] bullied him huh
i i don't know the exact reason i bet
you yeah he was
he was getting death threats and [ __ ] i
think well i'll tell you this man if i
met that kid in person i spit in his
[ __ ] mouth
how about that that's how much he how
good he is yeah that was literally
spit in his mouth yeah you son of a
[ __ ] no but i i always
love um that's why i love seeing kind of
like interviews of these actors work
where i'm like dude they
played such a [ __ ] like good role of
a
like a villain or of a certain character
i want to see
if they actually talk like that or their
their their mannerisms are like
most of the time it's like completely of
course they're [ __ ] acting yeah
people don't get it man that's not
getting me this like
that's like uh getting mad at [ __ ]
michael b jordan
right because he was a villain in black
panther you [ __ ]
yeah you know how dare you he died from
cancer i'm like
he was acting in a film you son of a
[ __ ] what are you talking about you
stupid [ __ ]
he was also creed don't you forget that
that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah that's apollo creed yeah [ __ ]
actually
yeah yeah but dude harry potter has
crazy fandom man
like no i know it does yeah i even had
the the app to see what
school i came from dude gryffindor baby
what do you mean what school you came
from like so there's uh
what school you're from so in harry
potter there's a magical hat that
assigns you to a specific school within
the
wizarding school so yeah you can be
hufflepuff gryffindor
um slytherin or
some other [ __ ] okay there's four of
them yeah um and so that hat
looks at into your thoughts and your
your your past and your history and who
you are your personality to place you in
a school
so uh do they have an app for that where
you answer a bunch of bunch of questions
to see what school you end up in oh okay
so you gotta add i was like the [ __ ]
this app doing looking into your
says i belong in uc berkeley yeah put it
next to your ear
yeah scanning complete yeah
and so they'll do that and then you can
find out what patronus you are and so
patronus is a spell that reflects who
you are on the inside
and then and then and it fights off
these these demons called dementors you
don't know what the [ __ ] i'm talking i'm
like
okay i know i know i remember the
mentors because
michael scott talked about it
i know that the mentors are some sort of
monsters from
harry potter yeah i'm guessing but yeah
mo like 98 percent of what you said i
have no [ __ ] conclusions
probably the funniest thing that ever
came out of harry potter was during the
time
when um they would do these book drops
and with book drops just like shoes or
anything else yeah
people who are fans of the series they
were hyped and
so they would line up outside of barnes
and noble's
and just to cop these books yeah well
there was this clip online where a guy
he actually had an early copy of or
downloaded the pdf it got leaked and he
read it
and so these kids were waiting for this
book he rolls down and
he goes dumbledore dies oh
no this kid drops on his knees and he
goes
i [ __ ] hate you it starts crying
on the spot yeah that [ __ ] made me die
laughing
so hard that's pretty cold though you
know because i hate [ __ ] who
spoil [ __ ] for me you know like movies
spoilers tv show spoilers
so like dude if you're that into it
i mean i could only imagine what you
know because i
don't know who the [ __ ] this dude is the
character you just mentioned and and him
dying yeah or he or she i don't know but
i can imagine if it was an important
character and and that and then somebody
just ruined it for me and i've been
waiting for this [ __ ]
like for for god knows how many years
i would i would slip that [ __ ]
that little kid comes out with a pocket
knife
yeah i would be like oh you just you
just [ __ ] got a deathwish that [ __ ]
was hilarious
to me i couldn't stop laughing because i
was a fan of this series too but they
told me dumbledore died i was like
cool spoilers don't ruin the film for me
okay um
because even if i know that it's gonna
happen i forget about as i'm watching
the film because i'm so
enraptured cause i knew a lot of the
stuff that people told me about game of
throne game of the thrones yeah
the game of the thrones uh ahead of time
yeah but didn't ruin it for me ah
speaking of that that like that's not
even a show i i think about now you know
it and it's so crazy how
it went from the most talked about most
watched show
to like absolutely obsolete in pop
culture because of the [ __ ]
the last season yeah well not only the
last season but the last like three
episodes yeah you know it was dumb
they should have ended the episode if
they were to end it like that with arya
killing the night king
they should just end it there for sure
anything but that yeah
anything but the way that we should kill
the night king i assume that that was
the last episode yeah and you know
people complain about the dark [ __ ] but
i actually kind of liked it because it
was like exciting i'm like yo what the
[ __ ] is gonna happen yeah yeah so when
that happened i was like oh this is a
really good way to end it and then they
continued and i'm like
what the [ __ ] is going on what is this
oh so [ __ ] disappointing i was like
sitting there like oh my god dude
i invested years into this [ __ ] and it's
terrible and it was so
[ __ ] good they went on like a
writer's strike or some [ __ ] right
or they know they switched off to
another project so a lot of the writers
weren't writing it or something i don't
know exactly what happened but then
you know i think uh starting from was it
eight seasons total i believe
and then starting from season seven they
didn't have the books as source material
so that's when they started to write
their own story i got you that makes
sense and
look they did kind of okay for season
seven
okay this is under the uh assumption
that there were eight seasons i believe
it was eight seasons but
yeah they did pretty decently for season
seven
started getting kind of questionable in
eight and then the second half of the
the final season was just like what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] about
um it's so bad dude the show was the
best
do you know what what the episode that
got me really into the show was the red
wedding oh bro
that's when i was like oh she's popping
off yeah that one dude
everybody got murked because i didn't
expect all those people
yeah bro that i mean i think that's why
people got so engrossed in like the the
whole world of game of thrones man
because it was
like nobody's safe nobody's safe and you
got these cunning [ __ ] who are
planning your death
you know and you don't even see it
coming and then
they [ __ ] did it and the way they did
it and i was like oh my god i wish i
never [ __ ] even started it when arya
just straight up poisoned everybody yeah
dog that [ __ ] was so dope i was like
this girl is cold-blooded
as [ __ ] she [ __ ] dedicated her life
to revenge
you know what's weird though when they
had the scene where she actually had sex
oh yeah
because it was so uncomfortable because
we saw her when she was a kid yeah you
know so watching i was like i i skipped
that part
she still looks like a kid though yeah
you know i mean yeah she's an adult by
age
as a person i remember when that scene
happened i was like i'm going to get
this party because i saw her since she
was a little
kid on the show i'm like nobody wants to
i don't want to see this
that's what i'm saying just these
questionable decisions yeah i'm like
what the [ __ ]
who the side of this [ __ ] you do realize
we saw him when she was like five or
some [ __ ]
and and like what it was more
disappointing was that george
r martin was still like an advisor
he still played an advisor to to the
show and so like
these are things that he ran by and
they're like hey you cool with it
yeah yeah so you cool with this girl
that we saw she was in adolescence gonna
have an
adult sex scene now during the same
series no it would've been a little
different if she was doing another show
and then you see her as an adult yeah
and it's like oh she but we literally
saw this girl grow up
yeah i do not want to see this all right
to say they made questionable decisions
in the second half of the last season is
a compliment
that's that's like that's the the you
know
least worst way to put it and it was a
[ __ ] travesty is what that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] [ __ ] goddamn shame you know it
was terrible yeah but
[ __ ] it is what it is you know i was
just like you know what all right
well i'm not the only one who feels this
way everybody
it's like the most unanimous thing that
you guys were so mad that like how dare
you i was like you as a cast member
you objectively know that this is a bad
news it just went to [ __ ] yeah yeah like
like none of the stuff that they kind of
uh
forebode made any [ __ ] sense at all
specifically with uh john stark yeah jon
snow
johnston stark tony stark john
john stark basketball yeah john stark
my bad josh josh stark
john starks no they forebode all this
other stuff
that that you thought was going to
happen at the end all that should happen
for no reason yeah
that just goes to show like the writers
are different yeah yeah there was a lot
of [ __ ] like the mysterious symbol they
made a big deal out of it ended up being
nothing they didn't even address it you
know
yeah so there was so much [ __ ] where
it's just like the build up
was was was great and then the reveal
was
a huge lecture it's like the last people
who wrote it they just
never watched the show before and they
started writing their own thing yeah
that's what it felt like yeah
it felt so disconnected and like out of
sync with what the show was
leading up to that now breaking bad on
the flip side
that was well they ended in four seasons
smart move yeah all you need is four
seasons
yeah i mean that [ __ ] through and
through till the end
was [ __ ] amazing you know man game of
thrones too when they came out with
those [ __ ] fine ass women just butt
naked
i was like i did not expect to have a
boner watching the show
that's a pleasant surprise i'll admit
because i had no i wasn't a fan of the
books going into it i had no
expectations
i remember people just started talking
about how great the show was i was like
all right i'll check it out
and i was like oh this show is violent
and it has features nudity
this is what i'm talking about baby yeah
and then i go back into my parents
bathroom
in the store and start jacking up again
oh my god
for a furious session of masturbation
it's like [ __ ] i gotta sell this [ __ ]
weave dude
that that is so funny you just in your
head you were deter like i need to
[ __ ] masturbate
right now so i could get back to work
and help my parents dude i'm a good kid
i did this for them i jacked up for my
parents dude
i could i could never [ __ ] do that
just in the middle of work
i went into the bathroom close that door
and i'll [ __ ] knock that [ __ ] out the
park
out the [ __ ] park i do it for my
parents you know what
that's talent bro i'll give you that
because well that boner wouldn't go away
dude it just wouldn't go away
it was annoying me it was gonna make me
mad no lube
just straight raw duck raw dog dude dude
luke does not make you jack off faster
you're doing it
way faster just more grip oh my god i
don't think i enjoyed it i just wanted
the boner to go away
hurry up hurry the [ __ ] up and get out
of my system oh my god and i left like a
spirit out of my penis and just flew out
that way
that's [ __ ] terrible well guys that
wraps up this
note on that note that wraps up this
episode of the jesus brain podcast you
can catch edric
at ed2 on instagram and also scrt
society
where you can go ahead and cop the gear
that we're wearing in this video right
now
[ __ ] fantastic and make sure you use
that promo code
brain 15 15 off for first time purchase
it'll be dope uh love you guys very much
make sure that you don't masturbate in
your parents store bathroom
unless you absolutely have to which i
did if you got to do it you got to do it
he did it
yeah we'll see y'all next time all right
shall peace peace